[Música]
ah
hay máxima expectativa en españa'
después de 355 días fuera del país el
rey emérito juan carlos primero regresa
a su patria el monarca abandonó de
manera voluntaria el país y fijó su
residencia en la ciudad de abu dhabi la
capital de los emiratos árabes unidos-
su regreso no se da en el marco de
ningún acto oficial o por algún motivo
familiar asistirá durante el fin de
semana a una competición náutica en
galicia y luego tendrá un encuentro con
el rey felipe sexto y su familia y
también con su esposa la reina emérita
sofía en el palacio de la zarzuela en
madrid el rey juan carlos de 84 años en
regresa a españa después de que las
autoridades cerraron las investigaciones
por presunta corrupción contra él y tras
una serie de escándalos sobre sus
finanzas su vida amorosa y las
excentricidades que llevó a su
abdicación veamos
después de un exilio de casi dos años el
anterior rey de españa juan carlos está
de regreso en su país sin tener radio
empieza en el noroeste de españa con un
invento de vela antes de concluir su
viaje al lunes con una visita a su hijo
el rey felipe en madrid el hombre de 84
años fue una figura venerada en el país
por su papel en la transición a la
democracia pero cayó en desgracia tras
una serie de escándalos incluyendo su
aventura con una empresaria danesa y un
viaje de caza a botsuana en los últimos
años de su reinado se descubrió su
riqueza oculta mientras surgieron
sospechas sobre tratos comerciales con
el monarca saudita quien asegura que
pagó 100 millones de dólares en una
cuenta bancaria suiza de una fundación
del rey juan carlos tras casi 40 años en
el poder ardico en 2014 y viajó a abu
dhabi en 2020 después de que las
autoridades españolas y suizas lanzaron
investigaciones sobre presunto fraude
los fiscales abandonaron las
investigaciones pero el rey todavía
tiene que presentarse en la corte
suprema en londres para un caso
presentado por su antigua amante danesa
que acusa el anterior rey de acoso tras
su relación
el rey emérito se quedará en la
localidad de sanxenxo en las costas
gallegas y está allí en esta población
que es donde don juan carlos
habitualmente visitaba a algunos amigos
con frecuencia iba a esta zona de
galicia antes de su exilio voluntario
allí tiene un grupo de amigos liderados
por pedro campos quien lo hospedará pero
qué piensan los españoles del regreso
del rey emérito veamos
no tenía por qué haber estado ausente
tanto tiempo tampoco
hizo cosas buenas yo pienso que debe de
volver a estar con su familia porque
mucha gente
como ya hay unos 20 años es tan elegante
su país y no ha hecho lo que ha hecho la
intentar remediar
no sé si lo ha hecho
supongo que lo ha hecho mal como supongo
no lo ha hecho mal pero también hay
muchas cosas buenas en españa
qué significa entonces para la monarquía
española el regreso de este
controvertido monarca de quien se
pensaba pasaría a la historia como el
rey que fortaleció la democracia en
españa y que también ayudó en la
transición del país después de la
dictadura de francisco franco que tan
fuerte está la casa real de los borbones
en este momento y que tan firme es la
imagen de la monarquía en españa' ha
podido el rey felipe sexto en su reinado
alejarse de todos estos escándalos que
provocaron sus familiares más cercanos y
que desenlace podrá tener entonces el
caso que todavía está abierto en una
corte londinense tras las acusaciones de
corina larsen por supuesto acoso corina
larsen que era una de las amantes del
rey el regreso del rey emérito es
nuestro tema de debate en france 24 y
para analizar este tema saludamos a
isabel fernández alonso ellas analista y
profesora titular de comunicación en la
universidad autónoma de barcelona y ya
se encuentra en la capital catalana y
también desde la misma ciudad se conecta
a esta conversación
joaquim coll él es analista historiador
y articulista ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos comentarios y
sus preguntas lo pueden hacer a través
de nuestras redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook también en
instagram y en twitter no se encuentran
como france24 bajo ese arroba sant y
luego que es mi cuenta personal y
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas le doy entonces la
bienvenida a isabel en la ciudad de
barcelona isabel gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa el día de
hoy y nuestro punto de partida para este
debate y para todo este análisis que
vamos a hacer de diferentes aristas
relacionadas con este tema del regreso
del rey y la monarquía no españa es que
significa entonces para este país
europeo para españa que regrese el rey
emérito después de su autoexilio en el
marco de estos escándalos y estas
acusaciones que había en su contra
bien buenas noches bueno la verdad es
que yo creo que se está exagerando
extraordinariamente en lo que
personalmente percibo como una como una
visita
más bien personal no
mi opinión particular es que hay una
presión mediática muy grande sobre sobre
este tema mientras que la monarquía
actual el actual jefe del estado está
desarrollando una labor pues francamente
buena creo no difícilmente difícilmente
cuestionable y la sensación es que a mí
personalmente me impresiona mucho toda
la expectación que se ha generado en
torno en torno a este asunto porque
finalmente se trata de una visita
privada quizás no muy bien gestionada en
términos de
comunicación pero pero no me parece que
tenga en que tenga tanta tanta
trascendencia este monarca picado hace
ya mucho tiempo y la monarquía sigue
sigue funcionando con normalidad
aquí también allí en la ciudad de
barcelona a punto de partida para el
debate lo que significa para españa el
regreso del monarca emérito y el
contexto de estas acusaciones que habían
su contra
hola que tal buenas buenas noches
saludos también a saber el nivel
pues sí a ver era un poco tiempo con
evitable el debate no por qué
el rey emérito del día se fue
envuelto en una nube de escándalo el
hecho de que hiciera irse de españa pues
para partido apareció ante la opinión
pública como una confirmación de diamond
ya que las sospechas no desde en fin de
de mala praxis no proponernos de falta
de ejemplaridad pública pareció que su
marcha de españa era aún más bien una
huída
bueno tal vez con el tiempo hemos visto
que pues que fue lo mejor o lo mejor
pues para
enmarcar distancias para sobre todo
proteger a la figura del rey felipe que
es esto para que los aspectos judiciales
se resolvieran ya prácticamente
resueltos hasta la cuestión ésta
efectivamente en gran bretaña
pero yo creo que con el tiempo más allá
de el balance un poco equilibrado de
decir fue ha sido un rey que ha tenido
un papel sin duda muy importante en la
transición ha sido pues capital su
decisión de aplicar en sus poderes no
porque el rey juan carlos tenía los
poderes a productos con nuevo en cuanto
a medio francos por tanto él decidió
poner esos poderes a los servicios de la
transición a la democracia un papel
histórico en ese momento y en otros
posteriores y esa falta de ejemplaridad
yo creo que eso con el tiempo lo último
que ha ido pensando mucho en que se ha
convertido en un juicio moral muy duro
contra él yo creo que va alejándose
también y con el tiempo pues yo creo que
el conjunto de la ciudadanía española va
teniendo una visión un poco más global y
más claro y sabes lo que hablaba
el impacto mediático que esto ha tenido
que ha tenido mucho revuelo pues lo
estamos analizando desde américa latina'
tanto así ha sido pero desde su punto de
vista que tanto es una estrategia
mediática tal vez para limpiar el nombre
del monarca después de estos hechos
acontecidos y después de haber estado
prácticamente dos años exiliados
acompañados de una pandemia donde
también la gente pues está distraída
como en otras en otros temas el tema de
la recuperación económica el tema de la
pandemia y el confinamiento y tal vez
sirva para limpiar un poco la imagen del
rey
y bueno a ver yo creo que también hay
que tener en cuenta la dimensión humana
es decir es el jefe del estado ha estado
envuelto en todas estas circunstancias
que desde luego en su dimensión
económica aquí coincido plenamente con
jokin co y pues por supuesto son son
cuestionables y es completamente
legítimo pedirle pedirle explicaciones
pero él pero obviamente hay una
dimensión personal y yo creo que
probablemente esta visita españa tiene
tiene mucho también de dimensión en
personal y de su propio sentir no por
haberse tenido que marchar de su país de
esa forma por todas las críticas y bueno
pues una vez que
se han resuelto favorablemente las
cuestiones judiciales bueno pues se ha
planteado hacer este viaje a españa y
supongo que hará más es decir yo lo
interpretó un poco así en términos de
bueno de una cuestión personal de querer
de querer volver otra cosa es que haya
un interés que yo creo que esto es lo
que
a mí me preocupa bastante en
determinados sectores en sectores
populistas porque lamentablemente yo
tengo una simpatía digamos por la forma
republicana de jefatura del estado pero
soy digamos de esos republicanos que
está conforme con el actual con el
actual jefe del estado porque le da
estabilidad al país creo en un momento
de mucha polarización no entonces
sectores que abanderan ahora mismo el
republicanismo en españa'
creo que están aprovechando de una
manera evidente y pone muy excesiva
todo lo que ha sucedido con el rey
emérito para atacar a la institución
monárquica
en su conjunto y esto yo creo que sería
un problema para la estabilidad del país
entonces yo creo que ahí hay unos unos
intereses evidentes que lógicamente
contribuyen a incrementar este impacto
mediático digamos eso me lleva isabel a
la siguiente pregunta yo aquí ya le voy
a dar la palabra también en torno a este
tema pero ya que isabel lo pone sobre la
mesa quiero preguntarle a ella si hay un
tema que probablemente genere división a
nivel político en españa es el tema de
la monarquía el tema de la corona sobre
todo entre psoe y unimos podemos y así
lo hemos visto en los medios españoles
en las últimas horas a raíz de los
anuncios y el regreso del rey en las
próximas horas a nivel político usted
habla de polarización isabel que tan
dividida está españa en torno a la
imagen de la monarquía la
institucionalidad del país a través de
la corona y la percepción que se tiene
de la monarquía como institución
bueno yo creo que yo creo que es un tema
que está más mucho más presente en la
discusión política que desde luego en
las discusiones de los ciudadanos creo
que es una de las de las banderas de
este partido de esta coalición de
izquierda de nosotros y de izquierda de
extrema izquierda que es unidad podemos
y de los partidos
nacionalistas
y los sacan continuamente es una cosa
que está permanentemente sobre la mesa
pero es que además hay un
cuestionamiento también del que no tiene
ningún tipo de fundamento del actual del
actor jefe jefe del estado los demás
partidos que son una que tienen una
amplia mayoría parlamentaria al margen
de que dentro del partido socialista sí
que haya habido siempre una parte un
cierto sentimiento republicano pero yo
creo que hay un consenso bajo un acuerdo
bastante amplio sobre sobre que éste
desde luego no es el momento para para
cuestionar ni mucho menos la forma de la
jefatura del estado que además está muy
blindada constitucionalmente es muy
difícil emprender una reforma de estas
características pero no creo que haya ni
la mayoría política ni tampoco desde
luego la mayoría social para llevarla
adelante joaquim y cuál es su impresión
sobre este tema la división a nivel
político la división a nivel de los
partidos veíamos que por ejemplo el pp y
el psoe no han dicho nada al respecto
dicen respetar las decisiones que tome
la casa real lo ven como una decisión
personal que el rey emérito haya querido
regresar pero hay sectores
parlamentarios
también el independentismo vuelven a
poner sobre la mesa la utilidad de la
monarquía en españa como lo ve usted
bueno pues que efectivamente ese es un
debate muy politizado en mi que hay unos
partidos que van a utilizar digamos el
cuestionamiento de la forma de monarquía
constitucional parlamentaria que tiene
españa en realidad para atacar el modelo
constitucional global del 78
entonces consideran que el eslabón débil
el modelo es la monarquía pero piensan
que puede ser este el eslabón débil es
verdad que juan carlos primero
y algunos otros familiares la familia de
la familia real
hemos tenido una ejemplaridad pública
insuficiente o
cuestionable muy criticable recordemos
el caso de garín
y bueno pues en base a eso intentan
hacer palanca no para
derribar el modelo constitucional y yo
creo que en la calle ese debate no
existe en realidad no existe en fin hubo
indignación y hubo digamos una censura
hacia algunos
comportamientos que se conocieron del
rey emérito con sus finanzas sobre todo
más que el caso del elefante digamos que
más que tampoco son actitudes que ayuden
y mucho menos y una cierta contradicción
entre lo que se decía en los mensajes de
navidad y luego unas prácticas en su
entorno pero yo creo que llega el
momento ya del perdón y el perdón porque
no podemos esperar presentar los
primeros se mueran para hacer un balance
sereno y equilibrado de su figura
histórica
entonces todas esas además existen y que
evidentemente
pues emborronan en su esencia ha sido su
peor enemigo digamos el peor enemigo de
su legado histórico es es su compuso
algunos de sus comportamientos
pues sí yo creo que llega el momento
pues para un poco para el perdón
reconocer es su aportación y bueno
efectivamente por sus errores que hemos
sabido y también fruto de un momento
histórico por el claro del también es
que se llega a españa en cuanto
terminado con unas culturas políticas
determinadas de consumismo de corrupción
y lo que no creo que se puede acusar al
rey emérito es de haber digamos robado
el dinero público y yo creo que sobre
eso nunca ha habido una acusación él
nunca ha robado dinero público el caso
pues ha podido ser comisionista ha
podido recibir regalos puedo decir el
dinero en fin de satrapías a árabes es
decir 'no conoces tales son pocos
cuestionables pero en su aportación
incluso para la internacionalización de
la economía española seguramente ha sido
positivo claro joachim desde su punto de
vista entonces es el lado humano
digámoslo así que presenta el rey cuando
ha pedido disculpas por por ejemplo por
el episodio de botsuana y las imágenes
que fueron dadas a conocer de estas
vacaciones en las que en áfrica cazando
animales también
el caso no del 2011 al 2012 estas
páginas ya fueron pasadas por lo menos
para la sociedad española fueron pasadas
para los ciudadanos y ya están en un
nuevo capítulo y simplemente el rey
puede estar tranquilo por lo menos
porque la sociedad lo recibe digan no sé
si con los brazos abiertos pero pero hay
una buena visión de su regreso
bueno no sé si buena o mala es que hay
gente que prefería que muriera en el sil
yo en el autoexilio y hubo un momento de
dudas sobre si finalmente el yen
regresaría nunca más a españa sobre si
las funciones judiciales tuvieran
diferentes pues igual no dependes
siempre digo que si la justicia volvería
luego hay también una ruptura entre dijo
con esto quiero decirte juan carlos y
felipe se sentó en ese es evidentísimo
yo creo que es el otro lado que es
también es interesante no como
felipe si sucede pero esto ha sido muy
consciente de que él no podía en ningún
caso cometer los errores del padre
digamos no y no podía permitir sin
ningún tipo de conductas creo que si
llegan al caso si no fuera pues
pendiente igual la situación de la
monarquía española sería mucho más
complicada pero el felipe ha intentado
establecer un cortafuegos muy importante
de hecho
hay un distanciamiento evidentísimo díaz
nunca más va a volver a residir en
zarzuela ni va a ocupar y va a vivir en
residencias oficiales del estado en
sentido digamos con carros tendrá
siempre siempre será un poco apestado
entre comillas en ese tramo yo creo que
el conjunto de la sociedad española
efectivamente ha pasado página de esos
de esos elementos que suscitaban yo creo
que como es evidente que por ella se
acerca el final
de su puesto y ojalá sea así pero claro
yo vemos un avance ser migrados se va
imponiendo
isabel allí en la ciudad de barcelona
estos dos factores clave también pueden
haber colaborado en mejorar esa imagen
de la monarquía en españa habló de dos
factores importantes uno el autoexilio
del rey
emérito y también esa decisión de felipe
sexto de desmarcarse de su padre como lo
estaba diciendo yo quien de suspenderle
ese salario anual que le daban al rey
emérito de unos 220 mil euros como parte
de la de la casa real también haberse
desligado de los negocios de don juan
carlos y también haberse
expulsado digámoslo así de la herencia
que pueda dejar una vez el fallezca esta
desconexión puede haber revitalizado la
monarquía en españa puede haberle dado
un nuevo aire ya en manos de felipe
sexto y doña letizia
bueno sin ninguna duda yo creo que la
el giro digamos los comportamientos las
actitudes del actual jefe del estado que
son completamente diferentes de las
últimas medidas también en términos de
transparencia y demás pues no están
mejorando sin duda no la imagen de la
imagen de la monarquía ya digo que
pienso que es más la crítica que
proviene de unos intereses partidistas
que estoy de acuerdo con lo que decía yo
5 y que van orientados a bueno a
dinamitar el propio modelo el propio
régimen constitucional
pero al margen de eso yo creo que es
difícil
a
recriminarle algún algún comportamiento
al actual jefe del estado aquí en
cataluña así que hay un ambiente de
bueno también más político que social
pero bueno también social digamos aquí
el rechazo es desde luego mayor a la
figura del jefe del estado pero tiene
mucho que ver con todo lo que sucedió en
2017 donde bueno el jefe del estado hizo
lo que tenía que hacer que es defender
el orden el orden constitucional y
recriminar a las autoridades catalanas
el intento de derogar el orden
constitucional de
directamente en el parlamento de
cataluña entonces el papel que ahí tuvo
el discurso del 3 de octubre
bueno pues para nosotros para muchos
catalanes para los que los catalanes
constitucionalistas de luego fue fue muy
importante lo valoramos mucho y creo que
ha sido también muy muy importante no
este discurso para su imagen en el
conjunto de españa eso unido ya digo a
los otros comportamientos en términos de
transparencia de marcar distancias con
los comportamientos de su padre pues
creo que bueno son conductas acertadas
que coadyuvan claramente no a la
estabilidad política en españa y en este
momento de tanta de tanta polarización
que haya un poder digamos
moderador creo que creo que es
francamente importante y saber qué tan
influyente es socialmente esta monarquía
renovada en manos de felipe sexto y de
su esposa la reina letizia para los
españoles que tan influyente es para
ustedes la imagen de ellos dos lo digo
porque leyendo la prensa española
encontraba a uno todo tipo de opiniones
pero me llamó mucho la atención la
opinión del alcalde de madrid josé luis
martínez almeida a raíz de la visita del
emir de qatar que también por estos días
estaba en españa- se reunió con el rey
felipe sexto y él aprovechó como para
como decimos en américa latina' echarle
un poco de flores a la monarquía y al
rey en criticando aquellos que piensan
que es una institución del pasado y que
a la que él le reconoce esa capacidad
para transformar y para catapultar a las
sociedades que tan transformador ha sido
está este este reinado de felipe el
sexto para la sociedad española para
ustedes
pero yo creo que socialmente no es un
tema de debate la monarquía curar la
mente está mucho más presente en los en
los medios de comunicación y en europa
la realidad es que no lo podemos olvidar
cuando vemos los índices no de calidad
democrática por lo cierto es que
entre los países con unos índices de
calidad democráticos más elevados hay
bastantes
monarquías parlamentarias por más que
ese carácter hereditario bueno pues
choque en términos democráticos a veces
pero no hay que olvidar que son que
tienen un poder no puramente
representativo esto es lo que debemos lo
que debemos tener presente pero no sé yo
al menos y creo que mucha gente no
muchos españoles valoramos pues esa
moderación que introduce en una vida
política que está bueno pues es
excesivamente exaltada y yo creo que
este es el valor que aporta no es una
imagen de una persona desde luego con
una indudable formación que siempre
guarda silencio que normalmente no se
puede defender de todas las críticas que
le llueven no esto también es la cosa
una cosa bastante importante y sobre
todo que no hay comportamientos que se
le puedan achacar
a la actual monarca y por eso pienso que
los ataques se focalizan en su padre
porque efectivamente sí que tiene unos
evidentes puntos débiles claro joaquim
su opinión que tan
importante que tan transformadora
resulta esta casa real española para el
país en manos de felipe sexto en el
presente que tiene el país sí bueno
hemos de pensar recordar porque nos
olvidamos fácilmente de las cosas pero
en 2002 por ejemplo el historiador
británico paul preston y conocido muy
reputado iconografía de carlos que se
llama juan carlos primero el rey de un
pueblo quiero decir hoy parece que no
sea así que nunca fue así no juan carlos
un rey muy popular muy querido también
la reina sofía hasta o es que a partir
de un cierto momento en su aplicación
fue en 2014 digamos
seis siete ocho años empezaron a
torcerse empezaron a salir escándalos a
conocerse una serie de informaciones ese
momento pues estaban ocultas y eso en
medio de una crisis económica muy fuerte
como lo hacen cuentos me a partir de
2008 en realidad es todo empieza ahí
digamos no es ese tipo de
comportamientos pues fueron merecieron
un reproche social enorme y entonces es
cuando el arctic a su hijo pues claro
que digamos no tiene esa cordialidad
digamos 27 tiene ese aire campechano
digamos que tenemos en castellano no en
español de españa pues como tiene su
padre si sonreí mucho más serio más más
formal un poco más y era ticos y lo
queremos también porque efectivamente
tengo que establecer esos cortafuegos
pero yo creo que la figura de felipe es
esto
para muchos catalanes y españoles pues
se entiende perfectamente
perfectísimamente en 2017 con su
discurso cuando hubo el golpe el intento
de golpe de parlamentario separatista en
en cataluña no es el aire efectivamente
ejerció su papel constitucional igual
que juntarlos y lo hizo de la noche del
23 de febrero cuando golpe militar no
son situaciones frentes pero
efectivamente juan carlos es una apuesta
clarísima por la continuidad de la
transición democrática y felipe es esto
pues se mostró como delante de la de la
unidad y de la continuidad del estado en
un momento pues es grave luego ha
seguido haciendo reformas
yo creo que
pues acabará siendo un rey más sino tan
querido como su padre y como su esposa
sofía aunque luego es hemos sabido que
matrimonio generalmente tenían muchas
desavenencias y gerenciados hacían vidas
separadas pero seguramente no será el
caso digo es igual de
de felipe y la reina de tiziano también
veremos pero es interesante digamos que
también son modelos matrimoniales
diferentes claro
pues yo creo que con el tiempo pues será
un rey tan tan querido y tan apreciado y
tan valorado por su formación altísima
formación preparación
como juan carlos fue queridos por su
cordialidad su en signos usó
acercamiento al pueblo no se
quedan todavía pendientes para el rey
emérito una causa en una corte
londinense una causa por acoso impuesta
por su ex amante coordinar sen
que es uno de los puntos de estallido de
todas estas acusaciones en su contra y
de todos éstos
y escándalos que hubo en torno a su vida
amorosa a su vida privada y esto me
lleva a preguntarme esto qué puerto
podrá llegar esto hasta dónde podrá
llegar cuanto más podrá afectar al
monarca emérito ya las acusaciones en
españa y en suiza fueron cerradas
subsanadas son tres investigaciones que
fueron ya archivadas se puede confiar en
la transparencia de estos procesos como
lo ven ustedes y saber
bueno yo sobre con las resoluciones
judiciales procuro ser muy prudente no
básicamente porque uno no conoce desde
luego todos los detalles lo que sí es
evidente es que bueno el propio el
propio monarca al regularizar su
situación bueno reconoció que había unas
irregularidades de esto de esto no cabe
duda y esto es claramente reprobable lo
que pase en el proceso abierto en el
reino unido porque la verdad no lo sé
pero claro es muy diferente que quede
todo archivado aunque pudiese haber
alguna alguna consecuencia yo supongo
que si todo es archivado
supongo que regresar a lo deseable sería
que regresase pues discretamente no en
mi opinión no a vivir a españa
y probablemente creo que también hace
falta a mi modo de ver y probablemente
lo hayan pensado y probablemente estén
esperando a que se cierren todos los
procesos judiciales algún tipo de
pronunciamiento algún tipo de comunicado
que tendría que acompañar digamos a esa
vuelta a españa si si todo se resuelve
yo creo yo preveo que se puede ser el
desenlace esa era mi pregunta de
conclusión isabel ya la vamos a ampliar
en los pocos minutos que nos queda de
del programa joaquim su su opinión sobre
sobre este tema hay transparencia se
puede confiar en estas investigaciones
en las conclusiones a las que llegaron
que puerto puede llegar esta
investigación en los tribunales ingleses
bueno pues la verdad no lo conozco muy a
fondo pero yo creo que la sociedad
española sobre esta cuestión ha pasado
páginas más amorosas sentimentales
y todo eso yo creo que la gente
sinceramente pienso que tampoco le da
mucha calidad a las acusaciones de esta
señora que tiene también unos intereses
económicos evidentes entonces bueno pues
una parte un poco de lío es decíamos
amoroso emocional sentimental de de la
vida de juan carlos de la vida privada
juan carlos primero es
edificante y si queremos pero eso es un
juicio moral que tampoco nos corresponde
mucho hacer que siente que entonces
bueno yo creo que se tiene entonces
cuando se cierra este capítulo
como se cierre en realidad hoy yo creo
que efectivamente en aumento puede ser
el rey emérito que volverá
a vivir a españa para morir en españa
seguramente
y yo creo que bueno poco a poco digamos
se irá imponiendo una visión digamos un
cierto perdón en sobre sus errores sus
de falta de ejemplo en algunas
cuestiones pero dando una visión pues
más equilibrada sobre su figura su
figura histórica bueno creo que queda
claro el punto del futuro que pueda
tener el rey de mary todos los dos
van más o menos por la misma línea que
existe la posibilidad de que regrese a
españa y pase sus últimos años allí es
por lo menos lo que uno de los
escenarios posibles y que muera en
españa rodeada de su familia y de su
pueblo creo que no hace falta que
profundicemos allí pero entonces
hablemos para el cierre para estos dos
minutos que nos quedan de programas
sobre la familia como tal
ya hablamos de la figura de corina un
amante un matrimonio con la reina sofía
que tuvo muchos problemas a lo largo de
los años se especula mucho sobre la
unión de la familia de cómo están ellos
entrelazados y cómo están ejerciendo sus
diferentes labores dentro de la
institucionalidad monárquica esto es una
familia compacta o se muestra compacta
por lo menos sal hacia el pueblo español
pero al interior de ella tiene muchas
fisuras diferencias
también teniendo en cuenta todos los
escándalos que han tenido las infantas
y le pregunto y sabes
bueno yo la familia creo que es evidente
que está
claramente
dividida es decir la familia real ha
quedado realmente reducida
al reírse
la reina y digamos sus hijas es decir
las infantas la heredera y las dos
infantas vamos y creo que está bien así
es decir creo que con todos los hechos
que se han conocido
en particular el caso urdangarín y demás
creo que es un acierto es otro acierto
más de
delación jefe del estado que la verdad
es que no lo ha tenido nada fácil no ha
tenido la situación que ha heredado no
no era nada fácil y todas nuestras
decisiones pero yo creo que no podemos
olvidarnos tampoco del componente
personal por esa parte del estado no han
debido ser fáciles yo creo que son
correctos yo aquí me quedé viendo su
conclusión se me acaba el tiempo tengo
que dar paso el informativo quiero
agradecerles a ustedes por haber hecho
este análisis para todo el público
latinoamericano de france 24 ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales y sigan viendo la
programación de france 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]